nous sommes ici devant l'hôpital des
esclaves et nous allons vous présenter
la généalogie de la famille karl
c'était en 1998
notre association l'association gandil
elle crée depuis 1993 et fédérer 16 en
de mémoire en quête de son enquête de
son histoire et pas dans le 150e
anniversaire de l'abolition esclavage
nous avons voulu faire des recherches
généalogiques
nous avons constaté que en 1848 les
patronymes attribué à aux esclaves de
cette ancienne plantation de ses
patronymes là on le retrouve encore à
villèle et nous en avons contacté
messieurs arsène carlo et nous a donné
l'autorisation
et nous avons entrepris des recherches
généalogiques aux archives
départementales
après l'avoir fait au mérite bien sûr on
a pu remonter très très très très loin
car la famille carlo fait partie des
premiers premier espère aider cette
famille et la surprise est que nous
sommes tombés sur véronique tard l'eau
qui était donné par l'eau c'était une
infirmière à l'hôpital les esclaves nous
trouvons devant cet hôpital par hasard
c'est pas pour mieux connaître où elle
travaillait véronique carlo fait partie
des ancêtres de arsène car nous elle est
décédée même est ici dans
dans l'enchère comme esclave de venelles
du bassin à villèle en 1852 et par
rapport à nos connaissances au musée de
villèle nous avons fait appel à une
artiste madame anne-marie valencien elle
va faire un très très beau très beau
travail est d'ailleurs monsieur harcèle
carlo s'est rendu plusieurs fois à son
atelier sa maison même à l'église les
prenne l'église de saint juniauds et il
va dessiner arsène karl où elle va faire
une très très belle présentation
regardez bien au niveau de la généalogie
en bas là et à l'époque de rené carlo
des saisons quand même c'est très sombre
et l'idée est d'aider l'artiste et de
nous-mêmes était de faire en sorte que
il ya c'est tout ce côté ses côtés
difficile à l'époque de l'esclavagé et à
la pollution et plus à monter puis ça
monte on remarque qui a plus de lumière
et ses lumières pour montrer à l'époque
n'est ce pas là c'était difficile et
puis ça monte
oui s'il ya on va dire plus de sourires
sur les visages des
des gens meurent au nectar l'eau on peut
la revoir su à la généalogie qui se
trouvent dans l'hôpital des esclaves